I think that it's quite difficult once
you get to a certain point to to stay on
top fashion is quite a flooded
marketplace so when you're spending time
and money designing product and then
people are like copying it for less or
and that kind of thing it makes it quite
difficult but at the same time it's
competition it's good it's fun and it
keeps us as companies you know trying to
give the customer what they want and
they have more options
[Music]
I'm Connor Walker I'm 26 and I'm the
founder of house of CP I creative
director hillbrand
I have a design studio in London and I
direct the designers on what we're doing
what stories we're doing we've done then
also I handle the business side so all
the marketing and everything else that
goes into growing a brand
I was always entrepreneurial when I was
growing up I feel like my parents are
both entrepreneurs as well so that
definitely helped they used to work on
the market and I used to sell in the toy
section sell is a loose term I was like
five I stayed at school until I was 18
and I did my English arts and economics
and then I just I left I had already
started house TV when I was 17 so it
started to do somewhat okay I was always
just more concerned with doing something
creative and making money and getting
out of there and just doing my own thing
I've never felt like a nine-to-five or
like going to uni and these kind of
things that we're told we should do to
be successful are things that we have to
do to be successful I feel like you can
just carve out your own path at the
first moment like a big celebrity war
house TV was Jennifer Lopez on her cover
of aka album and I was so excited like I
was going crazy and it was such a
surprise so that was great but now we
just kind of get them Topshop actually
Beach out to us they wanted us to you
know open up a concession in their
pastor street store we trialed that and
it was just phenomenal it kind of blew
up and then they wanted us to roll into
so many other stores and now we're in
about 40 top shops
the UK and in the US and their top
concession that they've ever had I'm
definitely the target audience and
actually think that that's always worked
in my favor
because I've always understood what
market wants and what our audience wants
so it's been pretty easy